come on bring on the noise hey what
happened
you look different oh go man can he win
okay then just take about family out of
there baby
[Music]
whoa hello oh okay I'm not a very good
Luke Skywalker if you know what I mean
let's see I've got to destroy the Death
Star yay that guy died I hope he wasn't
my dad or anything
yeah don't know where we are
[Music]
okay I'm upside down already okay okay
that was a lot of machetes that might
have been a little overkill let me out
please I'll do anything I'll give me my
body my soul my heart my love I'll give
my love my love no it's not her bird
army come on let go let go let go let go
let go let go let go let go let go oh
just let go why won't you let go please
let go of the ding dong damn thing come
on ninety three point seven four percent
impossible whoa I didn't go anywhere
these days are kind of a nightmare
oh I was gonna make it
ow okay
[Music]
take that JP this is how much I have
ever burning hatred for you running
murderer well oh look out I'm an old man
who is ready to stab you in the butt he
has ding-dong I don't know so funny epic
tree swing This Is It this isn't exactly
oh I think I'm supposed to let go oh my
god oh that's morbid hurts hurts a lot
hurts a lot hurts a lot hurts a lot that
looks painful and so it goes still
moving am i done are you done are you
kindly done dying yet sir please I'm
gonna have to ask you to move on Tower
Hamlets kill your boss well where is my
boss I seem to already be dead I'm gonna
kill my boss of a throw by like a yo-yo
[ __ ] just wait until I can get some
ground traction if I like with it here I
would tell the F out of your bra leg get
out there like I'm trying to kill my
boss leg leg leg
get out of my face no no come on just do
it for me but too fat a little craps
right Shiori throw Jordi Jordi god damn
it at least you and me went down
together JB Wow I caught it with my face
therefore I'm the winner victory ciao
babe I'd come on come on a little bit
higher at least I did ballet no you get
out of here what they're trying to kill
me [ __ ] yeah yeah Wow
hi JB ever get you there yes right Nana
Nana Nana Nana Nana
nananana nanana on what did I win we win
the eyes no need to die this time I've
got the rest of our lives
alright hey cowboy okay don't know where
we're going to these wines are yours
today
Oh bye everybody bye easy open run run
is but alright
right easy over easy sighs your phone is
good only at that landmine but I can
okay I might as well have dammit
come on come on so hard guys you don't
even understand
I get the all the excitement of trash
truck simulator 20 2012 scared babe
pardon me kids I know there's horribly
exciting for you but I need to go on my
daily rounds of picking up trash that's
my job sure a lot of dead bodies in this
neighborhood but I don't ask no
questions I ain't no narc
Justin Bieber fall I don't know what
that may all this is what that means
okay
[Music]
okay am i dead I'm dead
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you anymore
thank you it's really hard without a
spade boost in the beginning
luckily my giant butt will be able to
shield me from all these arrows also the
dead body my son I seem to be killing my
club that is a lot of blood not so bad
so far all right I'll take it
get back you are a lucky duck
I got it I got it I'm with it I'm with
it I'm with it I'm with her okay was now
with it where am I going now no come on
come on come on come on very difficult
very difficult very challenging very
challenging
oh here we go
[Music]
I saved you I saved you okay I split in
half but I won okay
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah do it
don't oh I made it through I don't even
like the Pogo levels and I made it
through your stupid level fantasy forest
Wow
it's magic what the hell is that oh
there's a bird okay I did not know those
monkeys were gonna kill me okay I didn't
know oh it's so pretty and pretty and
I'm dead good isn't this pretty
okay I need to make it through this
because this work there's a lot of work
put into this level and I don't want it
all to go to waste
whew no God you stupid monkey ass I
found this great vacation spot they're
wicking goddamn good isn't it lovely
the bus bus is easy yeah well you gonna
give me a raise because that said you
could work here do this Terry I never
figured out how to get past chairs
hello boss boss no I'll save you what
you're gonna fire me I'm out of this
relationship baby on my own forever ever
gotta kill me dead lost my Arbus Dookie
gonna try this happy adventure again
take my son and not me please kill him I
want to live for another day
Indiana Jones gonna survive today except
amidst my rope box of a most regard
though Burt go down otherwise Oh
celebrate it out for it Burt Burt okay
just
Carolyn Oh 100% impassable hundred
percent 100% okay
no thank you I need to get away from the
baby apparently slow down why would I do
that
scan bay find me I'm a that went up my
balls but that's okay alrighty then hi
baby
hello goodbye why don't you like the
Dark Souls I don't want you to do
anything wrong bye this is fine I got an
axe that's good right I thought that was
gonna kill me at first so oh I get it
that's very cool was I supposed to grab
that too was that important to me oh no
no I beige all right there's ward
I'm dr. gardener cuz I fixed up that's
warden two-tone die I'll be really
really Oh jet fall how I love thee okay
give me another try it's success here
don't just kill me right away that
wouldn't be very fun it's not very fun
to destroy all hopes and chances I think
I'm like a pretty ballerina
I shall go where I need to go down the
side and body won't get into the Lord
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye